PARRA: Moving to New York can be
lonely, like really lonely.
-The last man who touched me
was... my dog. -(bark)
When I decided
to try online dating,
I didn't anticipate
how many extremely specific
Web sites there were.
When did dating
become so segregated?
So I hit the streets
to ask New Yorkers
if they have any discriminating
dating preferences.
-Now, you're an avid
online dater? -Yes.
Okay, and have you found
that you have certain
racial preferences?
No, not at all.
Okay, so,
when you go online, then,
-are you just (bleep) free
for all? -It's a free for all.
I mean, I don't have
any preferences.
Whatever color you are,
I'm swiping right.
Are you at all inclined
towards certain races?
-No.
-No? -No.
PARRA: It seemed like everyone
was willing to bang each other,
but social psychologist
Tessa West
had a different perspective.
What's tricky is, people often
aren't even aware
that they sort of harbor
these more deep-down,
under-the-skin
racist attitudes.
So you get liberal whites
in New York, for example,
who are pretty much willing
to say that they'll date anyone,
but they don't really mean it.
What minorities are most
affected in the dating realm?
African-American women
and Asian men.
When you guys go on these apps,
are there certain races
that you're just going
to say "no" to?
It's bad. I usually say no
to Asian guys.
My dad won't pay for the wedding
if I marry a black man.
Like, you might... you might
just want a Labrador retriever,
-and, like, not
a golden retriever. -Yeah. Yeah.
I don't, like, dislike
golden retrievers.
I just... I just...
-You just don't want
to (bleep) 'em. -Yeah.
-Have you dated a black women?
-I have not.
-Have you actually dated
a black man? -No, I haven't.
-No black pene in that
white "V"? -No. -(laughter)
Is there a race
that you haven't dated?
Every race besides white,
but that's not my choice.
That's just youth and
inexperience at this point.
-Youth and inex...
-Circumstance.
-I'm a little boy.
-But is...
Because it's all about me,
I needed to see
if this is something that
I could be guilty of as well.
So I sat down
with matchmaker Emma Tessler
to get to the heart
of the matter.
I tend to think of myself
as someone who's very open
to dating all sort...
Well, like all sorts of guys.
I've dated white guys,
black guys, Asian guys.
I mention I'm Latina,
I'm Mexican,
I've never dated a Hispanic guy.
-Okay. -Never,
and I tend not to be...
attracted to Hispanic guys.
-I'm not racist, right?
-No, you are. Did you say...
(bleep), Emma.
-That's not the right answer.
-Of course you are.
-Why... -Of course, of course,
you're a little bit racist.
We're all a little bit racist.
Overwhelmingly, my clients,
personally, regardless
of their race,
would prefer
to date white people.
That's (bleep), man.
-Yeah, it's totally (bleep),
yes. -That's (bleep).
Now, you are the creator
of a dating Web site.
-That is correct.
-Which is called...
WhereWhitePeopleMeet.com.
So...
Yeah.
Because you feel like
white people
don't get to meet each other
often enough or...
-Uh, that's-that's not correct.
-Okay, okay.
It's not just for white people
to meet other white people.
-Anybody can join.
-Can I join?
Yeah, I think you'd have
a lot of... a lot of hits.
Is that because I can
kind of pass as white?
Like, let's be
100% real right now.
Um... yeah.
White people--
what is it about them
that makes them so appealing?
They tend to just
have more clout,
they have more money,
they have more opportunities.
I'll be honest, they have some
great qualities.
They-they like
artisanal cheeses,
they enjoy a good spin class
here and there.
Because of that they
sort of check all the boxes
for what it looks like
to be a high-status person
that you potentially would date.
Is there a little part of you...
a little part of you
wondering why
you've been mostly
inclined towards white women?
-Definitely.
-Okay.
I don't want
all this Whole Foods,
-matcha tea-drinking business.
-No,
you want Nabisco-eating
regular women.
You know, yeah.
Based on statistics,
who would be
most interested in me?
And let me just give you
some of my excellent qualities.
I cook very well.
I love Hanson.
I floss every single day,
uh, sometimes twice.
Um, I have terrible eyesight
but I like wearing contacts,
so that's fine.
I have huge teeth.
I look great in jewel tones.
I'm extremely close
to my family,
uh, except for one aunt.
Um, my grandparents
are all dead,
so you don't ever
have to worry about, like,
weird interactions with them.
I'll eat chocolate
every day of my life,
um, breakfast, lunch and dinner.
I don't need an alarm. My body
naturally wakes up at 6:45
every morning 'cause I'm super
hyper and it's kind of a curse.
Uh, I can fit into 5 1/2...
size 5 1/2 shoes,
that's a big deal.
I can fit into small spaces
in general, I'm a tiny lady.
Based on that,
who would be interested in me?
Probably Mexican men.
All right, I admit it,
I'm a little racist.
But so what?
Paid for by Donald Trump 2016.